mon avis c'est qu'on a toujours le choix
sur la façon de raconter les histoires
tristes
veut on peut tout repeindre en rose et
se consoler même des pires galères avec
une de ses chansons préférées
j'aime bien cette version là comme
toutes les filles seulement ce n'est pas
la réalité la réalité c'est souvent des
amis pardon ya pas mal je m'appelle
augustus waters et je suis en rémission
depuis 18 mois
maintenant si tu as envie tu peux parler
de tes angoisses avec le groupe mais
angoisse est tombé dans l'oubli
c'est quoi ton nom azali tournoi en
entier hazell grèce l'inca staff
pourquoi tu me fixe comme ça parce que
tu es belle bon c'est quoi ton histoire
j'ai été diagnostiquée à 90,1 vraie
histoire signifie tout à fait banal tu
peux pas accepter ça
tu sais que cus parle de toi constamment
c'est juste un ami j'espère que tu as
conscience que tu as froideur envers moi
ne diminue en rien l'affection que je te
porte c'est parce que je suis une
grenade ou un jour je vais exploser
je vais tout détruire sur son passage
je veux pas faire de mal
dans la vie on souffre on n'a pas le
choix mais on peut choisir qui nous fait
souffrir
je suis tombé amoureux de toi at-elle
grèce je sais que l'amour n'est qu'un
cri dérisoire face au néant et que
l'oubli est inéluctable et je suis tombé
amoureux de toi tous tes efforts pour
moi tous et ça marche un pas
là
s'ils parlent d'un triptyque
tu es en colère super en colère l'acide
et courtois
tu m'as offert l'éternité même si nos
jours sont comptés si tu savais à quel
point je suis reconnaissante pour votre
petite fille dignité
la vie est belle à cette adresse un
calcul
ok